we went out on the street we asked kids
to explain why they think women get paid
less than men and this is what they had
to do such a fruit
[Music]
I think women get paid less than men for
the same jobs
girls don't work as hard as the boys
what are they doing instead of
W girl
like what kind of other stuff texting
and running on the track why do you
think that women get paid by talking
about her mom no
um
why do you think that women get paid
less than men
um maybe women aren't acting as they
should maybe they're acting weird so
people think that they're
shouldn't be treated as fairly as men
would be how come the women make less
money than men because probably some
woman in California don't really have
jobs why do you think that women make
less money than men I think these are
very underrated because they can do more
but people expect them to do less what
kind of more can they do I love how they
act like the propaganda is like it's
it's honestly just too funny like they
add like the fake soundtrack or they
have like the big bar it's like clap
clap clap the kids said women are better
the women are better the constant
[ __ ] on of men is just dead funny
it's dead funny like it's not even like
they made them clap when they're like
yeah there's like equality like you know
they're equal it's he's like no women
are better and then you're like and he's
been taught that he's had that he's had
that sad smashed into his head it's one
thing if you just say everybody can grow
up and be whatever they want why not
just teach the kids that not women are
better than you the future is female
that's my least favorite shirt in all of
our
if it's all female it's not going to be
any future because we can't get anywhere
without the men no but I find it funny
that they they go after Tate for saying
men are better which he doesn't even say
yet then they they post this stuff where
women are better and then they it's all
the Clauses we have to smash the
patriarchy
it's like why can't like men just be
good at things and women be good at
things and we're just like all happy and
I don't know because I've explained this
to you they don't have real problems so
they could they need to feel like
they're they're part of something big
and part of something important so they
make up problems and then just blow them
up and blow them up and blow them up
into and actually they're really good at
convincing people that these problems
are real it's crazy isn't it it's
disgusting well a lot of people
underestimate them and they could do so
much more there's jobs that men can't do
that women can like what
like they can be an actress if they want
and a man can't be an actress
they can they can do whatever their
heart tell them to do how come the woman
gets paid less the woman my like maybe
like do stuff a little bit wrong but she
still
um gets paid less why does she do stuff
a little bit wrong
because maybe she doesn't know those
stuff and maybe they didn't teach her
those stuff but the guy knows that's
adorable do you think women are not as
good at jobs as men yo this kid's a pimp
just kidding yourself I want to buy that
little girl ice cream like it's just so
cute this kid looks like a straight yeah
baller with the leopard shirt the chain
this kid's got the hoodie open he's
legit adorable
I they're very good and they work all
the time like my mom
they work too who works harder
mom
equal rights how do you think we're
gonna make that happen you do have equal
rights Maybe
what rights don't you have what rights
don't we have all right all right she's
like 12 so let's calm down for like a
second no because she's got her mother
and her teachers and her friends telling
her that she's oppressed look at this
[ __ ] child this beautiful Aryan child
like she's like oh yeah I'm so oppressed
like yeah we do know you got it [ __ ]
easier like calm down Prince oh cool
maybe let's see if we have like a good a
good group of people to help around the
world or maybe a good president who
could help and who would be a good
president to help with that
um
Donald Trump let's go because
he can
I think he thinks of women and men the
same and equal why do you actually that
is everything he's ever said that's
actually the truth but they have taken
because he said that you can grab him by
the you know what in that video remember
that time when he was just talking to
that locker room talk locker room time
it was supposed to be um
that's horrible that's horrible imagine
they took the PlayStation parties that
we had and they they were like this is
sunny I'd be in jail I'd be in a
Romanian person I'm gonna tell you the
truth you know I worked in the music
business and what he was talking about
is being rich and famous you know yeah
you can grab them by the you know
whatever and it is true it doesn't mean
all women he means those leeches that
hang around just waiting praying for
some attention from a rich famous guy
there were women that just are around
waiting to be grabbed and invited back
to the hotel room so you know what
that's who he was talking about he
wasn't talking about Hillary Clinton
give me a break you're saying like if
there's just a girl on the street I'm
sure it's yeah I know I know that little
girl less money than men for the same
jobs
is this giving you a headache
why do you think that women make less
money than men take an answer let me
take a guess
I don't know but she's cute
well probably because women care about
shopping
let's go
shopping online and that's
yeah
have you ever seen that happen
no but I think it I think that look how
cute he is too women make less money
than men
uh because men work harder harder and
like real estate and other jobs how do
you know that because my dad's a real
estate agent have you ever seen a female
real estate agent uh yes I've seen a
couple and you think they don't work as
hard
I think this slouch
the funny thing about little kids is
like these aren't their thoughts they're
their parents so if you're asking them
it's like it's legit what their dad says
in the car when he's pissed like he's
[ __ ] with these women agents they're
all slouching and it's just he's just
regarding well here's the thing about
that particular I feel like there's a
lot of particular real estate agents if
anything no well in Boston where we just
came from yes our neighborhood was
dominated by female the female agents
were the top two I know in our in our
neighborhood and yeah that's fine like
you're you're basically a Salesman like
construction workers you're not seeing
you're never going to see remotely as
close like the hard jobs like let's just
be real and like that's fine why do you
guys want you don't want the hard jobs
physically hard jobs you mean I mean
yeah like that's what you know like yeah
mentally hard like everything well the
real estate example is just funny
because not only are there a lot of
women in real estate it was cute that
the kids said that but that's a
commission based it's commission based
so yeah you aren't making the same
unless you want to make the same amount
of money but not have done the same yeah
it's not like women make four percent
and then the men make five yeah not how
it works
way than men
well the rules and there's always male
presidents wait for it wait for it it's
not about a female president
if there was a female president do you
think all that would change
I think that'll ever happen I hope so I
hope not less money than
me
if you love clicking buttons and
subscribing God save us God save us from
a female president given what we've seen
as our possibilities no thank you oh
yeah yeah that was funny all right thank
you guys so much for watching make sure
to like subscribe join my Discord I have
a free preview and some free sauce that
I'm giving out only to some of you guys
you have to join and open a ticket yeah
you get to speak with me and follow me
on Instagram at sunnyfast and we'll see
you later
[Music]
[Music]